[Music]
yeah look at them here it'd make you
better between me and you Magnus that's
fake I saw one once was it it was so
fluffy I thought I was gonna die how
could you let Balthazar's rats just get
away you're fired
he really did to snuggle with I miss
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me hey could you oh of course
now as I was saying I good my seriously
oh I really must have a word with you on
behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother my brother
I can't doesn't love this guy look at
him
Alvin here would make you better look at
this face I'm so mad you must see the
beautiful wife oh sweet talker this
place is amazing it's nice like gasps
you're I'm not really into things
Masek Grumio leaves in your blood Sigrid
gun boobs you ready to continue the
family tradition
you and me no I left that life behind me
just one
[Music]
I'm going in okay
this does not mean you're going back to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
heights music